Among the many lessons we can learn from
Fire Lord Ozai, here's the top three.
One, the dangers of unchecked ambition
and hubris. Number two, the corrosive
nature of toxic family dynamics. And
three, EDH players are great at finding
synergies but terrible at evaluating
them. What do I mean by that? Well, you
see Ozai's ability, mana equals power.
Okay, we found the line, boys. We filled
the deck with big power sackfoders
turning three mana into seven, even
eight. Wow, look at this big dumb warp
guy. We're netting six mana. That's like
one free Ozai activation. But after all
this, how much value are we getting?
Really? Italy players should know this.
When you flip just the top deck, you
whiff a lot. Especially when unlike
Italy, you don't even get to flip your
own stuff. And you only get to pick one
spell among them. So you're not winning
with quantity either. So, all of this
work for just one flip. You're you're
probably better off ramping harder, like
an artifact deck, chaining rock into
rock, and you should be able to get to
two activations fairly quickly. And at
least rocks can do other things, too,
like powering out fatties that actually,
you know, do things which Ozai can also
eat. That seems like a reasonably
powerful direction, but then at the same
time, we want an Ozai deck. If we just
want big mana decks, then there are
better options. So, it's a difficult
line to walk. Trying to maintain a
deck's identity while avoiding traps
like these. So, I had to keep looking.
But among the dumb idiots, one stood
out. Malignus. Yeah, this one is not
like the others. This one is huge. We're
easily getting three activations with
it. And this, in my opinion, is worth
spending a turn on. Barely, but it's a
decent enough game plan. So, what if
instead of these, we dedicate our card
slots to tutoring for and recurring
malignance? almost like a secret
commander type deal. And if we can
consistently devour Malignus once or
even twice a turn, that's a solid
magical Christmas land scenario. Every
deck needs a Christmas land and we are
looking for the season ticket. So, we
are tutoring. It really is annoying how
black and especially red has never
printed anything even close to this for
13 years. So, we need to make sure we
get this card malignous all the time.
And while we try to avoid infinence, the
deck does play a bit like assembling
mini combos. So getting the tutor for
the different pieces is still pretty
important. Yeah, tutors are good. Hot
take. Anyways, we've got nine of them.
That's like having nine copies of
malignant. Intomb variants are a bit
risky, but we also do have a bunch of
reanimation spells. Scheming symmetry is
chosen because of interesting political
implications when combined with Ozai's
ability. Even with all the protection we
can give, which frankly isn't too much
in the Ratos colors, the possibility of
losing Malignus forever to a source of
shares or just a piece of graveyard hate
is real. So, we do need some backup
plans. Ulamach and Sewer Nemesis. Yeah,
quite a downgrade, I know. Expensive or
inconsistent. Ideally, we wouldn't have
to call on these idiots until mid to
late game. And when we do, they should
be at least maybe 12 power or more,
which is serviceable. Also relevant when
Malagnus' power drops. inevitably with
opponent's life totals. Ulamog is also
interesting in that if you get to the
point, you can attack with it and Ozai
and still get the massive annihilator
trigger before sacrificing it for mana.
And since we're looking to use
malignance over and over again, we're
packing the deck with these undying
effects. Some of them even pump the
creature a little bit. That's awesome.
And a reanimation package for the same
purpose, but also to work with the the
inmb effects. I love that Zuko's
conviction fits here. So now we have an
engine going. Every turn we can activate
Ozai three times. That should give us
enough advantage to keep up with the
game and potentially look for ways to
win. But why stop here? Now we're in
combat with 90 mana floating and a fresh
malignance. An extra combat or two
sounds like a decent idea. We prioritize
the instant speed ones because of the
mana we get during combat, but these
heavily discounted ones should also do
fine. The undying spells along with any
sack outlet is solid protection for our
commander and the malignus. But just a
few more to keep things extra safe. And
just a few pieces of extra value. Nefosy
to copy our stolen spells. Flare of the
hatebound and terror of the peaks to
trigger with malignus over and over
again. And finally ramp. We have a
decent number of rocks here and the
herborg coffers package. That's quite a
few cards dedicated to ramping. It's
because a lot of our stuns here can be
mana hungry. And more importantly, our
commander is an outlet that can
potentially turn mana into everything
else. For draw spells, we have the
standard getting a black market
connections on turn three is always the
dream play, but also a few that
synergize with a deck like disciple of
bolas and rune grinder. Stinging study
is interesting cuz usually people don't
play this unless your commander is huge,
but even five mana for four is not
terrible considering how much instant
speed mana we have access to. And
usually I'm a bit iffy with wheels, but
in this deck I think it's fine because
of how much we interact with the
graveyard and also we need to dig for a
tutor or a malignous fast. And that's
all. Yeah, we're not playing any answers
or other utility. Basically depending
100% on our opponents to feed us
ammunition for lens. We are going full
on utility. The MDFC's are always great,
but the most important lens here are the
sack outlets and this because maybe once
in a while we want to send Malignus in
for some beating. Erdza's cave as a
backup herb work or coffers and talent
skate of Madera as an extra form of
protection. If you haven't noticed by
now, the deck is not for everyone. This
actually deviates quite a bit from the
decks I usually build in that is really
swingy and inconsistent. It's got the
highest of highs and the lowest of lows.
When the pieces come together, we are
activating Ozai three, five, even seven
times a turn. But there will be times
when you're stuck with three extra
combat spells in your hand while Ozai is
busy disrespecting SOA. Another issue
with decks like these is they're really
opponent dependent. For instance, I know
for a fact I won't be doing too well
with my group because, no offense, but
they're a bunch of idiots. I mean, even
with three flips, I'll end up with a
shrine, some crappy aristocrats fodder,
and maybe maybe a draw spell. Also
remember, Malignus requires us to keep
one opponent at a high life total while
attacking the other two only, but Ozai
wants us to kill everyone at the same
time ideally because if we kill someone,
we lose their stuffs. Ozai becomes
significantly weaker when we have fewer
opponents. So yeah, this deck does have
some hoops we have to jump through. We
are living for that one glorious moment.
It's also quite costly because of the
tutors and technically higher than
bracket three for the same reason. But
in reality, it's probably a three at
best and self adjusting because we're
dependent on opponent's cards. Again,
not a deck for everyone, but if you're
bored and want something different, Ozai
might just be for you. This is Jyn with
Next Level Commander. Thank you for
tuning in to my third Avatar deck tech.
Please like and subscribe if you've made
it this far. Obviously, you like
something about my videos or you are
just asleep and in that case, sweet
dreams.